et pour en parler nous sommes ce soir en
direct avec alexis poulain notre
éditorialiste politique bonsoir alexis
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
havre qu'avez vous trouvé le premier
ministre convaincant on attendait
peut-être un petit bémol sur ces petits
commerces et notamment les librairies or
ce ne sera pas le cas on ne reviendra
pas sur les mesures a dit le chef du
gouvernement
il est convaincant pendant la folie en
fait qui est celle du gouvernement
depuis quelques jours quelques semaines
ou voit bien que ce confinement impensé
a totalement improvisée nous emmène de
mesures aberrantes en mesure aberrante
et là on a un premier ministre qui nous
dit qu'il est en train de fermer des
pans entiers de l'économie et que c'est
pour le bien des français et que l'on va
mettre 20 milliards sur la table pour
sauver ces secteurs qui sont mis à mort
par le gouvernement justement pour
lutter contre ce virus parce que
finalement on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait
lors du des confirmands jean castex
étant responsable de déconfinement il
avait fait appel je le rappelle au
cabinet bain and company pour gérer ce
déconfinement qui est un fiasco total
et le voilà ce soir sur tf1 expliqué que
c'est normal si on ferme les petits
commerces si on empêche les grandes
surfaces de vente des produits et si on
demande aux français de ne pas commander
sur des plateformes internationales des
produits il faut être bien sages ne pas
ne pas consommer du tout à seulement à
manger les produits de première
nécessité on a l'impression d'être
revenu dans un autre temps où c'est
l'état qui décide quels sont les
traitements autorisés ce qui fonctionne
et ce qui ne fonctionne pas sans aucun
bagage scientifique
quels sont les produits qu'on a le droit
de consommer dans les rayons empêchant
la grande surface là de travailler et je
pense que d'ailleurs le syndicat des
grandes surfaces va sans doute tapé du
poing sur la table et faire le sitting
devant matignon et l'elysée pour
expliquer que ça ne peut pas être fait
de cette façon là et puis enfin les
petits commerces qui ne sont pas dupes
qui vont qui voit très bien qu'ils vont
mettre la clé sous la porte
ce n'est pas les aides promises qui vont
leur permettre de sortir la tête de
l'eau
on a l'impression en fait que c'est un
naufrage que certains ont déjà pris des
canaux et que dans les canaux dans
lesquels on a pu monter et on est en
train de trouver le sol des canaux pour
être sûr que tout le monde va couler et
si jamais vous arriver à nager on va
vous mettre un boulet au pied pour être
sûr que vous voulez avec tout le monde
et après on enlèvera les boules et sert
à mieux vous verrez donc là c'est
vraiment un scandale ce soir dans
l'interview
de jean castex il n'a jamais été
question de l'éducation nationale du
fait qu'on va mettre des millions
d'élèves de professeurs de personnels
administratifs qui vont être au contact
après après les vacances pour refaire
encore à nouveau des foyers de
contamination
si on était sérieux sur ce nouveau
confinement alors ce serait quinze jours
de fermeture totale des frontières mais
de tous et télétravail pour tous les
métiers possibles et imaginables y
compris l'éducation nationale donc on
est dans une d2 mesure incompréhensible
encore une fois mais qui cette fois ci
sont extrêmement dangereuses parce que
on nous emmène droit vers une faillite
des économies européennes là on a
l'impression qu'on est plus finalement
dans ce qui marche ou pas pour endiguer
cette épidémie c'est plutôt une bataille
de concurrence déloyale alors si les
petits commerces sont essentielles
doivent rester fermés à leurs fermes ont
effectivement les rayons de ces mêmes
produits dans les grandes surfaces où
est la logique du virus mais il n'y a
aucune logique c'est à dire que c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé pendant
toutes ces années où en 2010 8,4 midi
ont été fermés ou les ars ont continué
de fermer des lits après le premier
confinement où la logique est en fait
totalement déserté ce pays c'est à dire
qu'on est dans le mira siona lite est la
plus totale la folie la plus totale et
aujourd'hui on a des élites qui font qui
s'agite dans tous les sens qui font d à
peu près tout pour éviter d'être jugés
de cette gestion catastrophique où des
morts qui pourraient découler du manque
simplement de moyens de l'hôpital public
et du manque de stratégies de
planification de l'état puisque le
déconfinement a été inscrit la sq au
total et c'est incroyable de voir la
démission globale de deux gouvernements
quand on à monsieur djebbari qui nous
explique qu'il faut en tant que parent
d'élève avoir une attestation pour
emmener son enfant à l'arrêt de bus mais
que l'enfant doit avoir une attestation
du de l'école à laquelle est enfin né
déjà rien que les attestations c'est du
délire et tous ses délires s'accumulent
avec eux maintenant demander aux grandes
surfaces de fermer leurs rayons demandez
aux petits commerces de fermer et
demandé aux français de ne pas commander
bien sûr sur les plateformes donc on est
là en train de ne plus savoir quoi faire
pour soi disant sauver l'économie
endiguer ce virus mais on a l'impression
que c'est des mesures qui ne servent à
rien ou alors vraiment a très peu cette
fameuse théorie des tranches de fromage
trou et qui font que additionnées elles
arrivent à endiguer le virus là c'est
pas sérieux c'est vraiment on a
l'impression d'un effondrement en direct
de l'appareil d'état les maires de
france certains maires de france ont
pris des arrêtés pour tenter de sauver
les petits commerces de leur commune
bono le vert aujourd'hui a dit qu'il
était inconscient pensez vous que les
français est il étonnant justement de
ces petites boutiques soient des
inconscients
non ils sont très conscients de ce qui
est en train d'être fait à leur commerce
à leur vie ils sont très conscients de
leur mise à mort et il se bat et les
maires font tout pour que leur vide ne
ferme pas les pas de porte et les
rideaux et les rues commerçantes et les
commerçants qui ont tout fait qu'ils se
sont eux qui ont mis tous les moyens les
protocoles sanitaires en place je pense
aux coiffeurs à tous les tous les
commerces qui recevait des personnes les
bars les restaurants ont été les
premiers bien sûr en souffrir mais tous
les autres qui ont joué le jeu qu'ils
ont fait ce qu'il fallait aujourd'hui on
leur dit eh bien on va vous faire mais
c'est pour eux c'est pour votre bien et
puis on va vous aider mais mais personne
n'est dupe ce confinement et jean castex
l'a dit même si les français sont sages
c'est pas sûr que le père noël passera à
noël ça va peut-être confiné encore un
peu plus longtemps
et puis va falloir gérer cette crise
encore plus longtemps sans jamais mettre
les moyens sur les protocoles sanitaires
en attendant un hypothétique vaccin qui
encore pour demain
alors que on nous a bien expliqué que
c'étaient les gestes barrière qui
comptait qu'il fallait mettre des
masques tout le temps enfin on a
l'impression que toutes les mesures
n'ont servi strictement à rien et qu'on
accumule des mesures qui ne servent à
rien pour finalement protéger personne
parce qu'au final c'est une banqueroute
générale c'est une faillite générale et
c'est une économie qui ne s'en relèvera
pas ou si tu entends des mois des années
peut-être dire qu'ils ne servent à rien
des mesures en tout cas que les français
ne comprennent pas en quoi une épicerie
serait plus contaminant qu'une librairie
ben voilà le livre produits hautement
contaminants l'épicerie pourquoi pas ça
n'a aucun sens donc comme il faut avec
cette fameuse concurrence libre et non
faussée faire en sorte que si les petits
commerces fermés bien les grandes
surfaces doivent aussi fermé leurs
rayons de produits non essentiels on est
dans une économie planifiée mais à
l'envers c'est à dire que l'état décide
quels sont les produits qui ont le droit
d'être vendues
parce que on lutte contre un virus on
est en 2020 on est en train de vivre un
moment incroyable de dystopie de 10
réalité parce que c'est totalement
irréel ce qui se passe avec des gens qui
ont fait des études qui ont des diplômes
qui ont fait l'ena et qui vous
expliquent très doctement très
sérieusement que c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et qui a pas d'autre choix et que
c'est la seule solution
eh bien les maires les commerçants les
français ont tous compris que non ce
n'était vraiment pas ça qu'il fallait
faire qu'on est en train de faire
n'importe quoi et qu'il faudrait oublier
à ça et je crois que là la limite est
atteinte et on le voit bien parce que
derrière les partenaires européens qui
vont vu la même stratégie que ce soit
l'italie l'espagne mais les pays où on
confine comme sauro pousse à fermer les
commerces
c'est une rébellion dans les rues c'est
une rébellion de fête où les gens font
semblant de jouer le jeu mais trouve les
moyens de contourner ces interdictions
parce que il faut bien vivre et là on
propose simplement aux gens d'arrêter de
respirer pour survivre au virus
seulement l'apnée pendant quinze jours
ben on en ressortait en bonne santé
généralement merci beaucoup alexis
poulain pour ces précisions ils verront
qu'ils parlent effectivement des fêtes
de noël peut-être faudra-t-il acheter
des oranges pour mettre sous le sapin
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse